this was a meeting that wasn't supposed
to take place until the 18th of april it
was brought forward actually we believe
uh in response to the fact that will
smith resigned from the academy
the the challenge that the ampas
actually had was really i mean how do
you punish somebody who has already
effectively removed themselves from that
body already he's punished himself
resigned from the academy so really i
think they wanted to be seen to take a
stand but they were fairly limited in
what they could do they couldn't take
away his oscar i mean only purely
because if we go on precedent for
precedent that's been set before harvey
weinstein who of course has been
convicted of criminal charges he hasn't
had his oscars taken away so i mean
comparatively
they're in a different league so you
couldn't really have taken his uh oscar
away from him so how do they punish him
well we've had this statement come
through tonight we're still getting the
details unfolding but all they've said
at this time is certainly that will
smith shall not be permitted to attend
any academy event or programmes for the
next 10 years following what happened we
think they're still in the process of
exactly sort of releasing the
information of what's going on in this
meeting today but yeah that's the quite
a bold statement isn't it banned from
the oscars for the 10 years especially
if you're a big hollywood superstar it's
hitting you where it hurts